it's about you
taking your life your children's life
the teachers the administrators their
life seriously and it's about doing it
at the local level the federal
government is not going to come in and
protect all 350 million people of this
country the data that i just laid out
there from pew
which is indisputable is proving that
this is not a gun problem it is a people
problem it is a mental health problem
and if we are willing to have that
conversation
uh then perhaps we can clean up some of
this and in a more broad sense if you
have a people problem if you have a
mental health problem instead of just
creating laws to manage those people how
about we think about something else so
now to bring this whole show full circle
i want to go back to that conversation
that i had
with ben shapiro and with jordan
peterson
ben
talked about the crisis of meaning that
we have in america and what that leads
to
and i think that
part of the resistance to particularly i
think jordan but i think also to me and
to anyone else in the idw who's at least
searching for meaning is that the left
has been saying for a long time that we
found the meaning right the meaning was
do what you want to do the meaning was
no responsibility do what you want to do
that's the meaning the meaning is
rebelling against the system and when it
turns out that a lot of people don't
find meaning in that that there is in my
perspective a god-shaped hole in
people's heart that is being filled by
hatred and polarization and tribalism
that god shaped whole right
the idea that nietzsche said god is dead
and it was a warning that if you take
out the structure that exists that
everyone sort of believes in to whatever
degree they believe in it you completely
remove that
people are gonna start believing all
sorts of other things right the need for
belief is so fundamentally important
that people will start believing in
other things people will start believing
that boys are girls and two plus two is
five and non-racists or racists and the
rest of it and maybe that
is far more of what really is going on
here than oh if we could just have the
law to stop this there's something else
going on with all of us and then when it
is hyper fueled by this thing do you
think that maybe is causing a problem
and when you find out that the powers
that be can manipulate us to see certain
things and not see certain things and
lie about certain things and all of that
do you think that adds up to a situation
where a young person growing up in a
very confused world without a lot of
good role models without um a system
that rewards people for doing the right
thing and instead rewards people for
usually doing the wrong thing
do you think that that could lead to a
whole bunch of stuff i think it could